we have a voicemail number it is two one
nine two david p here's an interesting
idea from a viewer about this donald
trump is exhausted thing that we've been
hearing about lately and how it might
relate to the future of trump take a
listen to this hi this is mica from
florida i just wondered what you thought
about the idea of all of trumps people
saying he's exhausted he said tired is
the build-up towards some defense for
his resignation
he signed he's resigning because he's
ill there's something wrong with him
i know he hates weakness but it could be
an out it does remind me though of the
Christmas invasion episodes from Doctor
Who
when David Tennant first took over and
he doesn't like what the prime minister
did so he tells her a hmm don't you
think she looks tired and that starts
off a whole rumor mill and she
eventually winds up getting voted out
right of office no I just wanted to see
what you thought argue a doctor who guy
I'm not I don't know what the caller is
talking about as far as that goes
I don't think so because of what the
caller said in the middle which is Trump
doesn't like to look weak and I think if
this entire Trump is exhausted thing as
a possible pretext of resignation were
were true it would go against everything
we know about how Donald Trump conducts
himself it would also require the Trump
White House to be thinking one step
ahead profit which I don't think they've
demonstrated thus far there's no
evidence that they have the ability to
do that on the bonus show today Google
tried to block media coverage of a
gender discrimination case against them
we will talk about the bogus nature of
so-called light and low tar cigarettes
and the connection to lung cancer we
will also talk about in the wake of the
horrible a terrorist attack yesterday in
Manchester England do we change our
behavior or at least our thought process
when we're out at certain types of
events due to terrorist incidents all of
those stories and more on the bonus
shows you can sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership